в українському суспільстві бракує знань
української історії ми маємо єдиний
марафон якщо він вже є
потрібен то очевидно що треба наповнити
смислами і якраз історичний смисл був би
дуже дуже потрібен тобто я прекрасно
розумію що можливо бракує коштів на
виготовлення якогось нового історичного
контенту але в нас вже є дуже багато
історичної контакту ті самі YouTube
канали будуть прекрасний історичний
контент Я переконаний що зараз
величезний попит є на інформацію яка
стосується історії і На жаль ми дуже
мало бачимось цієї інформації в
державних каналах YouTube канали
історичні - мій улюблений це
youtube-канал історія без міфів Тобто це
вже десь понад півмільйона здається там
підписників і так далі от я сам почав
проводити записувати YouTube канал цього
надзвичайно бракує і Росія цим
користаюся Росія цим користається Росія
продовжує якось колоти в принципі
суспільство упереджень знання історії